all right what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on and
today we have Jeff who joining us some
oh man hey I like the program thanks for
having me yeah this is appreciate you're
already like it yeah it must be because
we wrote your name and welcome on the
whiteboard over there and I mean
appreciate I mean you're educating the
world right I appreciate you know more
and more folks and platforms is putting
ideas out there so appreciate the work
we have we're just talking about
interdisciplinary the show is you know
just having conservative think-tank
Heather McDonald now having Jeff flew
with nootropics and biohacking and
ketones and all this cool stuff
enhancing human performance it's just
you know every day is just these kind of
different areas of expertise around the
world and let's make the goal the
mission let's make scientists educators
and entrepreneurs as impactful in the
world as athletes and entertainers yeah
amen to that I'm done for that let's do
it it's so deserved over time to finally
have gone to the point where people care
more about it so we have a great program
enhancing human performance just maybe
tell us a bit about your background you
were computer science at Stanford then
you started a company glass map yeah and
then yes so and then how did you go from
like computer science to enhancing human
performance yeah good question
as you mentioned I study computer
science at Stanford specializing in
distributed systems and you know I think
obviously in my first company for glass
map I applied those techniques for
figuring out and developing really very
efficient algorithm to track location
across mobile devices and we end up
selling that company that Groupon in
2013 so it's a great first journey
through entrepreneurship I believe I
sold the company just before I turn 24
oh yes that is what I'm talking about
yeah remember negotiating the
the terms over Christmas holidays this
is probably December 2012 and going to
January 2013 but I remember I guess for
me computer science or engineering was a
means to an end and solving interesting
problems was what I always had a
fascination with you know as a cage-like
building like I was getting that
childlike curiosity across interesting
problems and one of the interesting
problems I always had fascinated me was
this notion of enhanced humans I don't
know if you know this video game Deus Ex
you know where you could install Bionic
arms eyes increase senses seemed like a
very cool future I never thought that I
could you know do my career in this
space but I mean I think that that's
kind of like a later connection of the
dots but when I was at Groupon I knew
that a big company wasn't my cup of tea
and realized that you know a lot of my
cup of tea a cup of tea yeah I do like
tea like he's great and green tea is
great but I knew that you know just
looking around like Silicon Valley all
my smartest friends were making
computers better than making robots
better than making AI better and there
was a sinking notion that why aren't the
best minds in the world focused on
making humans better and I had and that
might be like a very altruistic goal but
from a personal level I just wanted to
be smarter well I could I learn faster
could I be smarter working memory
yeah working memory capacity reaction
time these are some measures in psycho
metrics for you know early signals of of
intelligence and that got me down the
path of this broad online community
around biohacking can we hack ourselves
with Russian altmer drugs illicit
compounds everything in between
there's compounds like new pep to
piracetam that are used in Russia
as Alzheimer's therapeutic that work I
guess in terms in terms of like big
clinical trials the the data hasn't been
clear there I'm I think if there was a
therapeutic I mean it's a problem that's
that that you know billion you know
billions and billions of dollars are
being spent on so you would think that
the compounds were very efficacious they
would be looked at but I think there's
on the other hand it's an obese
compounds are open patent so one can
make the argument that there isn't the
incentive to run you know a 1 billion 10
billion dollar RCT phase 1 phase 2 phase
3 FDA clinical trial to show efficacy in
America for Alzheimer's disease so the
skeptical side is there's no strong
robust data or randomized controlled
trials on these such compounds the more
optimistic it community could be likable
yeah in some ways these are open domain
you one cannot patent them therefore
there's not not that economic incentive
to look and invest into these compounds
so but I think in terms of the animal
models and some anecdotal and early
human data like is some reasonable data
there that suggests that something might
happen there but anyways I think that
just like a small slice of compounds are
interesting but there were a huge
community people and rapidly growing
community of people talking about
nootropics which is a umbrella term for
smart drugs or cognitive enhancers and
reporting interesting N equals one
reports around you know feeling
subjectively clearer feeling you know
more productive and that kind of
intrigue me as someone that wanted to
tap into that and there is as I
mentioned for some reasonable literature
building across different types of
nootropics not everything not saying
that everything that you can set says
that one purports is good for your brain
is good for your brain I mean I think
got a look at specific compounds but
that was enough to get me interested and
essentially creating like the first
versions of what is now called human by
the time was a service just
like make nootropics easier to access
because this was in 2014 I was just
importing bags of white powder from
Alibaba just like looking at like like
okay new Pepsi man interesting for a
scam seems interesting like bacopa
monnieri some of these botanical
compound seem interesting some of the
reports you know the research looks
pretty reasonable can i start pulling
together and you know experiment with
myself yeah and any pig testing on
yourself first yes
which in retrospect was a little rash
and aggressive but I think in some ways
also responsible in some ways like I do
it to myself before making a service to
do it to other people after yeah but
that got me down the path of looking at
humans as a platform and obviously you
know now with for years being in
business and really scaling up and
became a lot more formalized and
rigorous I think my systems training in
computer science really applies itself
really well to applying engineering
principles on the human platform yes so
what I think we're doing now is I I
think one analogy I like is what we're
doing now is the same cut of cloth as
the homebrew computing Club hackers
these garage hackers on silicon in the
70s and 80s tinkering with GPU CPUs
you know hard drives making beautiful
systems with silicon that same creative
hacker ethos is going on in the BAU
hacking community with tinker's on human
bodies with you know implants with you
know constantly you know blood panels
for example or like headsets that like
zap your brain or compounds ketones
nootropics
but of course the comb brew computing
club hackers evolved and formalized into
software engineers hardware engineers
electrical engineers and they're running
some of the most impactful companies in
the world in a very rigorous way and I
see the same thing happening with bio
hackers yes there is some crazy [ __ ]
going on I don't know if we can curse on
this program but Oh total
this is crazy there's some crazy stuff
going on like yeah I think wanting to
address it like you know people talk
about micro dosing LSD you know taking
off-label
Alzheimer's drugs is not as smart as
think perhaps but the industry will
formalize and become more rigorous and I
think there will be human performance
engineers just like there are computer
engineers today I love your vision
you're explaining the technology and
computing boom with analogous to the
biohacking boom that were about to
experience and I totally feel it I
totally see it I'm totally all over it
it's been happening since I was
mentoring at Indy bio yeah seeing all
their craziness what they're up to
hearing about this from people like Tim
Ferriss from people like Josiah saner
yeah right all these guys and yeah I
know you as well I'm really happy that
you're taking these like engineering
principles that you've learned and
you're applying them to what you're
experimenting with yourself and with
what you're doing a human so okay so now
we're at the point where you've you know
you're getting some stuff from Alibaba
you're you know you're kind of testing
it on yourself yeah do you do you feel
like I mean I guess first of all there's
the there's the necessity to want to
wait a couple days at least between
dosing up on something just so that you
can maybe give your body a little bit of
a break yeah in between trials but did
you feel and it's so tough because
subjectively we don't know when it's
placebo or not yeah so how do you figure
all of that out as you do with this yeah
so what engineering means to me is being
quantitative if you can't measure it how
can you optimize it right like
engineering is sort of the funny some
sort of objective function for a system
that you want that that is designed for
some purpose right so the more useful it
is that that purpose then you're fitting
some sort of objective function so for
nootropics for example it is you know
cognition and what is cognition well
there's components of being smart which
being a most psychologists source like
you know what would classify as you know
working memory capacity reaction time
there might be attributes of resilience
you know or resistance to fatigue
for example emotional intelligence yeah
I mean I think those are like more and
more fuzzy right it kind of gives you a
little bit into the like the
psychedelics gives you a little bit into
the vibe yeah more of people and that
that kind of stuff yeah there's
definitely I think there is definitely
some quantitative way to understand that
I think for sake of simplicity some of
the things are on a reaction time for
example are just easier to understand
easier alright like people you can
actually just measure yourself as
opposed to going too fuzzy yeah my
writing memory could get a little also
easier to yeah exactly so exactly so
just as we're talking about it you know
like there are just designed tests that
are in psychometric labs I just showed
like okay different numbers how many
digits span you're bringing these in the
psychometric test so long exactly I
nootropics exactly it's exactly how you
actually build up you know quantitative
data on what you're doing otherwise and
it's like yes subjectively I feel better
or I don't know oh yeah then you can
play like to soup or not like we're just
like guessing each other so I think
refer to the RCT data refer to actual
quanta quantitative results okay walk us
through randomized control trial walk us
through that and walk us through the
psychometric tests yeah that you're
doing so how do you even structure um 10
or 50 or 100 people that are doing this
what are they taking walk us through
what are the measurements of you that
you're doing before and after yeah
randomized control trial short RCT is
known as the gold standard for clinical
trials it means that the randomized part
means that you know if you collect from
a population of people you're testing on
you randomized them into treatments
right and controlled means that you
blind it and usually it means like
double-blind it's so like the person who
is administering the intervention which
is like a nootropic or a ketone or
placebo
you know me as a it like the scientist
is not I don't know what I'm giving you
and then obviously the person that's
taking it doesn't know what they're
getting so you're controlling from
inadvertent information transfer by you
know someone like oh you've want me to
do well on this you like you you you
clear that out yeah and there's you know
notions of you know doing cohorts we're
like you can switch batches for like you
have one cohort on the placebo one
cohort and then you you know run an
experiment on them and then you switch
them to us again the intervention
so essentially you know there's just
like well understood methodologies to
eliminate bias essentially yeah so you
can more and more go from a correlation
to a causation sort of statement and you
know it's the same style of experiment
that you know you would run through a
pharmaceutical trial right you
randomized control and intervention
intervention versus a placebo so for our
nootropics we were light on existing
bodies of the corpus of data but for the
ketone product the ketone ester which
had interesting nootropic elements you
know a lot of the data was run you know
you know again at RCTs against existing
you know gold standard which is like
carbohydrates so can you have ketones
versus carb drinks and can you tell
different human performance measures
right so one of the results was
published in 2016 was showing that
ketones plus carbs you know athletes
would go 400 meters further in a
30-minute time trial for for a bike race
which is pretty significant when you're
counting that you know these are elite
cyclists I mean it's you know almost
like a you know half a kilometer that
you're going further 30 minutes so you
know there's some interesting
unpublished data that shows there's an
interesting impact for ketones for
enhancing high res decision-making that
we hope to publish soon so I risk
decision me so for example
you know if one is in a stressful
condition can you i I I'm Bulow's to say
too much in terms of just like we're not
sure should I buy at the store high risk
I don't want to do you know obviously
just academic proto you want to kind of
scoop you know you know pre publication
of work but this will give you a high
level sense of it there's gambling tasks
that one can do in terms of like playing
a game like if we choose a color in this
unknown box or there's like you know you
choose an you know a number you know how
often are you making the right decision
to win you know a dollar and it's been
showing across a couple studies now that
ketones are are more efficacious and
helping you make a better high res
decision roofing all right
let's loop us into we'll get back after
what you guys are doing with cycle
metrics and analyzing that why don't you
teach us what ketone is what is that
yeah yeah yeah no that's good that sort
of zoom back so when we started we store
like the nootropics world and like the
kind of N equals one stuff we quickly
realize that fasting was actually one of
the most compelling ways to improve
metabolism improve metabolic profile and
there's some emergent data that it can
improve cognitive focus and performance
yeah in in the sense that fasting is
associated with elevated brain derived
neurotrophic factor which and of itself
is a compound that increases near on
growth neurogenesis etc what is the
compound in the body when you fast that
increases neurogenesis BDNF elevates in
a fasted state but there's more data it
shows that ketones or the mediating
metabolites that triggers the enters
that yeah so again like you have to
deprive your body of the glucose that
it's usually powering itself oh yeah and
so that's kind of where we get to what
if what fasting is fasting so fast
because it doesn't even require you to
take anything in to try and increase
your cognition and all this kind of
stuff increase your metabolism you
literally don't take anything in yeah
and then that is how you can
subjectively then go and feel what the
difference is like but for most people
it's so scary oh I can't get over that
first grumble when the first grumble
comes it's almost like that uh that
evolutionary sign for them and then it's
if we could recommend you to try you
know one thing from probably this whole
conversation would be to go at least one
day without eating food and just see how
you feel the next day when you wake up
in the morning and then so now the
science you deprive your body of the
glucose that were usually putting
ourselves on and then we're able to burn
excess fat correct and then that is when
we drop into a state of ketosis and that
is when ketones to do what's going on
there yes so one of the evolutionary
functions of ketosis that you mentioned
was that our bodies can only store a
limited amount of glucose in our liver
called in a form called glycogen
typically around 20 24 hours interesting
so yeah so one day exactly so we would
be kind of a shitty animal if we just
couldn't find food for a day and we go
brain-dead right like we would not have
survived so obviously you know we are
thriving as a species now and that was
due to the fact that we could actually
use fat as energy but what was
interesting but why humans are
especially good at using fat is that so
glucose can cross the blood-brain
barrier so that's why you have duck the
adage that like your brain needs sugar
to function and fat can't cross fatty
acids cannot cross the blood-brain
barrier so what happens well humans
evolved to be actually one of the best
animals using keto Kito's ketones is
because our fat gets converted into what
are called ketone bodies in the liver
into things called beta hydroxy butyrate
acetoacetate and there's a third key to
embody that sort of like a waste
particle acetone I'm gonna breathe out
but BHB beta-hydroxybutyrate is a small
molecule four carbons it can cross the
blood-brain barrier so really evolved as
a backup fuel to feel the brain that's
so cool that's the evolutionary aspect
of it
so as we hibernate when we have to go
the day or two days without food as we
go in front food that we have Ellucian
airily our body's figured out how to be
able to you you run out of glycogen in
your word in your liver and then your
liver burns fat yeah and B H B
beta-hydroxybutyrate can then put
surpass the blood-brain barrier and give
your brain the power and then what about
this whole ATP concentration like
glucose has much less ATP than fat does
well well well I think it's it's a more
of like a I guess complicated story
write it just like ATP is the energy
currency for our body right it's like
basically what our mitochondria produce
and there's like multiple pathways to
fuel the mitochondria essentially and if
you remember from high school biology
there's a website called the citric acid
cycle right so so fatty acids if you can
sort of recall are just like long chains
of carbons and there's a process called
beta oxidation that takes two carbons
out of the fatty acids and then feeds
into the Krebs cycle and then for
glucose there's like pollicis which
takes glucose turns into pyruvate and
that feeds it into the Krebs cycle and
then ketones are interesting so ketones
from the beta-hydroxybutyrate turn of
acetoacetate turn into acetyl co and
then feeds into the krebs cycle so
there's basically just like multiple
paths pathways that feed into the
mitochondria and it feeds into the Krebs
cycle so the interesting point which I
think you're getting to is that ketones
are 28% more efficient than glucose
premium oxygen so you get more work done
more power generated if you will from a
ketotic state in the mitochondria versus
a glycolytic state in the mitochondria
per oxygen molecule because these are
all a little bit rusty these are all
aerobic respiration processes yeah yeah
per oxygen molecule 28% more energy
efficient to burn fat to burn ketone
specifically tones yes yeah
then it is glucose yeah interesting okay
so then after doing all this then you
realize that maybe then now if we can
figure out how to get like a ketone
drink all this good stuff and yeah and
then test it now we can maybe get into
the psychometric so yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly so that's where the story gets
interesting so fasting one of the most
robust interventions to extend perhaps
longevity to improve metabolic markers
and reduce signs or cause remit
morbidity and that's been oh it's a
pretty robust right fasting / caloric
restriction and one thing and there's
different hypotheses on how that works
but one of the things that caught my
attention specifically was that when
you're fasting you you you lower your
dependence on glucose you you you let
your body sort of reset its resistance
to insulin yeah and then there's this
interesting notion that you ketones kick
up and there's a lot more data like just
this is the cutting edge of physiology
now that shows that ketones are
interesting signaling metabolites for
BDNF that i described before but also
triggers you know pathways associates
longevity like Fox o3 and some
implication on the sirtuin pathways as
well so that got me thinking
huh is fasting you know what you know
what is the magic when you don't eat one
of the interesting things is that
ketones rise okay we just go directly
there that and half our ketone levels so
that got me looking into
technologies I think that one could come
up with to attack that specific pathway
and this is where the story you know in
terms of science academia industry comes
in startups comes together really nicely
where our research partners at the
University of Oxford and NIH published
the paper paper in cell metabolism one
of the top metabolism journals
biochemistry journals showing that the
previously that I mentioned the the
British cyclist study that an exhaust
ketone ester could enhance aerobic
performance reducing lactic acid
production but I think the highlight to
me was like you can make people go
better or go further go faster you
improving performance and you're also
elevating people's ketone levels really
really aggressively and I you know and
then the world kind of nicely collided
where at the time
human or nutri box a time the previous
name for human was running one of the
largest online and intermittent fasting
groups and we were getting coverage
across us but also getting you know a
feature in the BBC we fast yeah we fast
is what the group is called how many
people are in that community in over
20,000 so it's it's it's interesting I
remember when we did we did a seven-day
fast at the start of 2017 over 100
people joined us to do a seven-day just
water fast which is like kind of nuts to
find a hundred people in the world is
just like 90 for us some days we there
is that that's another interesting you
know anecdote but I've won five I'm
trying to give props yeah no I think
after three it's like the hard part is
over we can talk about but that would
oppose up the story I got in touch with
the principal investigator on that
research project her name is Professor
Karen Clark she's one of the most
ten-year professors in the physiology
Anatomy genetics department in Oxford
and she's been studying ketones and
ketone on tablets for last you know 20
plus years and she's been looking at
ketone Esther's exhaust ketones for the
last ten plus years and you know we long
story short signed exclusive partnership
to bring her technology into a food into
a food and bring out to the world we've
so she has her self manufactured a
ketone Esther yes well yeah in
partnership
yeah we're bringing that to the world
but okay so she's been testing different
ketone esters and then now you guys are
also helping her test and put it into
some sort of a fun branded product that
will resonate with Millennials and Gen Z
people sure I mean I would say that it's
not necessarily for Millennials or gen Z
people I mean I think our current
customers of ketone of human ketone our
professional teams and a full teams MLB
teams grant or cycling teams really
military organization so it's not like a
little tear so it's not like fine I mean
I want to have like a fun ski at some
point I think that ketones should be
more considered a fourth macronutrient
but it's really a high performance
product so they give you a sense of the
history DARPA had at RFP a request for
proposal for it's interesting that like
the nickname on the projects of
metabolic dominance can we create a food
substrate and metabolic substrate to
enhance soldier performance in multi-day
physically and cognitively demanding
missions so hell yeah we can yeah it
long story short that was what Professor
Clark and her main collaborator dr.
Richard weeks at the NIH started working
on multi-million dollar grants animal
studies human studies safety studies
from a kinetic kinetic studies going
through the FDA process from you know a
research chemical you know that used to
cost you know twenty five thousand
dollars to produce like a drink just
across town
yeah so with in it so yeah you should
just be super expensive to something
that you know you can just retailing for
$30 ring which is still expensive but
hope you know hopefully still you know
working that cost curve are you guys
like being kind of made in the massive
bioreactors these breweries is that kind
of word ya know that's like that's a
great insight so that's actually one of
the technology changes that were taking
an advantage of so most organic
compounds are made through a practical
chemical process right like you brace
through a fine petroleum and some of the
lighter compounds are smaller smaller
carbon chains right so the interesting
thing with ketones is that specifically
beta-hydroxybutyrate is that it's a
chiral compound meaning that there's an
L form in a deform so they're kind of
like mirror images of each other and
that's like a common property across a
lot of organic compounds I know nothing
about organic chemistry but yeah but a
high-level think of like a left hand and
right hand you cannot overlay them
together unless you like flip it right
so like you know they're the same if
five fingers we can't stack so your body
your liver only produces the
beta-hydroxybutyrate hmm so L form is
useful the body L so there's some open
debate on that
so our research lead doctor Briana
Stubbs showed that it doesn't really get
metabolized so it kind of just hangs
around in your system some researchers
would say that L form has its own unique
signaling properties and might get
converted in the D form you know the
other school of thought is that it's bad
for you it you know the disrupts uptake
of the DHB bhp I don't think that story
is fully resolved I mean let's look at
the data but anyways there's unknowns
around the LP HP I think is scientific
consensus oh you're so lucky to have
them
Oxford and NIH this is yeah no I mean I
think it's a outscoring them yeah yeah I
may think it's been a wonderful
partnership I think it's really I mean
to just you know it's elevated the rigor
of our process yes and I think you know
conversely I think we're able to also
just turbocharged the speed of industry
of Silicon Valley until I kind of like a
slow moving academia right so I think it
looks like a great partnership
partnership on both ways yes I mean I
guess so one of the complications I
think of the chemical process that
getting the only D PHP is important so
that's like an expensive process so
addressing your initial point yes you
basically be HP computer 2d yes okay
that's what you want how do we get the
other so one of the recent advances that
is you can use genetically modified
organisms GMOs to ferment from sugar or
other starter material into the exact
form of the organic compound you can
genetically modify sugar or yeah you
know the modified ecoli yeast other
factories essentially and it's made a
self-replicating environment and that's
how we're starting to bring down the
costs awesome yeah okay cool and so this
is kind of your is how much what
percentage of the company human is
focused on that aspect well we see
ketone as the future of the business
yeah it's almost 100 percent done well I
mean I think you know we've created a
multi-million revenue business off of
any tropics products and that's still an
important business line for us but I you
know moving forward you know the data
the science the the depth of what we can
do with ketones is super exciting so
it's you know kind of like expanding out
the mission to encompass a little bit
more than just nootropics
yeah so let's tell us about you said
athletic teams are using it or peak
performers are using it who's using it
right now and then what were those
psychometric
trials like for you before and after how
are you measuring that it's like yeah
yeah yeah so a number of metrics are
tracked so you know most of the public
published data is focused on the
physical aspects but again talk at a
high level at the of the psychometric
studies and also some of the published
research on animal models etc so they
went 400 meters further yeah so in
elites British cyclists cyclists were
going 400 meters further in a 30-minute
time trial this was in between this was
in 39 a study on 39 British cyclists and
there's always questions around Oh can
we have more n yes we can always have
more end but of course that's also based
on the fact that one you know the the
results were static significance you
know p-value you know less than 0.05 is
typically considered significant by
leave for the big experiment you know it
was you know well under 1% in terms of
the p-value and then also if you look at
the body of sports physiology and size
that are just like kind of lower in the
population because it's like hard to
find elite cyclists period so this is
not that many of them maybe with
basketball players or football players
or other yeah yeah well I mean I think I
mean that's all part of like the
assessment process right like you make
sure the end size is gonna give you
enough power to make significant
conclusions there was a study done on
elite British rowers for example
increasing on average 50 meters in a
30-minute time trial which is pretty
significant as well some of the other
metrics that were important was showing
that we reduce lactic acid production
lactate by 40 percent and lactic acid is
one of these things that some of the
athletes that might be listening the
kind of thing that associated when you
get sore it's like get lactic acid
buildup and what that's usually what you
get after you workout yeah so yeah so
yeah
in the tablet so what happens is that
you're doing it so much you know stress
that your buddy gets out of aerobic mode
so it doesn't use o2 and starts
essentially fermenting sugar so pyruvate
glucose pyruvate turns into lactate and
as opposed to going to the Krebs cycle
because it's like a faster way to
generate ATP what's less efficient so
when you're like doing sprints to talk
you're making more lactate so when you
have a ketone drink you don't ester you
produce less lactate because ketones are
preferential energy source so one of the
interesting studies that finding is that
we've you know I guess Robi you know our
collaborate is found was that ketones
are burnt prep for lunch preferentially
as a fuel so you use ketones firstly
preserve your glycogen reserves and then
you just have like a double fuel band
usually the opposite when you well it
just it just doesn't exist in nature
I guess is that real fasting and then
you eat a little bit of food you drop
out of yeah alright then yeah so then
the glucose goes first yeah but with
exogenously tones they're used first
yeah if you eat something they're still
being used first yeah yeah I I would say
that the thing is that it's like a novel
state of physiology where in normal
physiology you have glucose and then you
have like low you're not presenting
ketones or when you're eating a kid died
or fasting you have high ketones low
carbohydrate and you kind of making
trade-offs or both and it's I mean
there's different advantages of being in
different states but you know for the
first time you can just consume ketones
directly and soft folk like you can
reserve so you know like both fuel bars
and that's why it's the interesting
interesting physiological effects yeah
yeah hmm okay so what does how many
teams are using this now yeah your
product yeah
so during the NFL season you know which
wrapped up I guess a couple months ago
we had a couple NFL teams using it
we're working with the spring training a
couple MLB teams baseball teams are
ramping up on it it's currently right
now it's like in the middle of grant or
cycling season so we're working a lot of
teams in grant or cycling so these are
the teams that compete in Europe on a
tour of France etc so I am a MLB team or
our an RN MBA team or any sports team
what is the person that does the
business development for human what do
they pitch what do they would itch the
science I mean I think how do they call
it they call it enhanced performance
through I mean I guess well I guess
enhanced performance enhancing is
obviously touchy
in the sports world so I guess the
caveat the whole conversation this is
what a compliance
it's people like compliant again a world
anti-doping agency so we actually know
anti-doping agency water yeah so like
the reason why you can't like eat
testosterone or or whatever is because
of water this imagine some just chugging
- Skyy okay you probably can't take it
orally yeah it will break down but uh so
it's just the cop yeah just say well you
know just the the proper disclaimer is
you know this is considered a food
ingredient we think of it as comparable
to glucose drink right you can drink
energy from glucose to put it well we
now have weighted drink energy in the
form of ketones yeah exactly
yeah it's metabolic substrate so it's
like it's like a feeds into the
mitochondria if you just call it a
ketone drink I think that's what you do
yeah that's pretty good way to put it
the same way you get a glucose drink you
know yeah I think we've been relatively
lucky in the sense that there's a huge
exponential increase of interest and
kidnet diets ketosis hold all right so
especially the strength and conditioning
coaches at these elite organizations you
know they're there for a reason like
they like know what's up so it's been a
relatively easy sell as and and
especially what we found is that there's
a lot of ex
DoD military guys that worked with like
the tier 1 special operators that were
aware of the DARPA program in the early
days that have now moved into the
private world and our elite SMC coaches
for NFL teams Oh baseball teams and all
this things so it's like so like it's
been lucky that sort of just tap into
the old network of the yeah the folks
that are aware of you know the interest
in the special operator community and
then getting into the network of you
know hey you know who do we know that
would be interested so that's been like
a kind of an acceleration of just like
educating people and the future goes
beyond athletes and military it goes to
even to general public as well a little
gap you're at the gas station or you're
at the convenience store and you're
seeing ketone drink on the shelf human
ketone drink and you purchase it for
hopefully three to five bucks yeah
hopefully and and then you can level up
both of your bars fill them both up the
glucose and the ketone in them well
that's definitely that's that's
definitely our hope so you know you know
one you know we used to make sure that
you know we can you know make sure that
it works well for the athletes we're
just starting to roll it out broadly and
then to I think there's definitely some
potential there there was recently a
paper published by our collaborator at
Oxford and University of British
Columbia showing that Akito master drink
reduces glycemic response compared to
placebo so if you drink a sugar drink so
this is how one diagnosis people with
diabetes for example you drink a sugary
drink your glucose your blood sugar
spikes and then like it doesn't really
fall because your body can't handle
sugar that well that's diabetes
essentially well with a ketone ester
right before you drink a sugary drink
your glycemic response is lower
and it also increases different measures
for insulin sensitivity yeah I mean I
think there's another whole interesting
discussion around ketogenic diets
fasting metabolic syndrome diabetes yeah
so so there's a good ketone drink before
you eat a chocolate cake I think that
would be quite sensible I mean I think
the data suggests that it is so another
paper that was published in November
showed that our ketone s or drink
reduces ghrelin as well so ghrelin is
the appetite hormone we drink no ketone
drink maybe you don't want to eat that
sugary dessert so yeah I mean I think
there's like there's clearly like the
public say that it's most robust around
athletic performance case yeah and we're
starting to explore additional use cases
Emory and oh yeah there's things that
we're talking about earlier yeah because
I think well it's like if you're a
[ __ ] metabolism at such a fundamental
level of just you're making your
mitochondria more efficient there's
obviously interesting downstream paths
that we can start hitting that's harder
to it's really hard to quantify
metabolism right
yes but I would say that yes I mean
absolutely you know but I think
interesting ways to start looking at
that is you know can we understand
people's
fasted blood glucose can we understand
people's h1 BAC these are markers for
how how much ambient glucose sugars like
floating on our systems so yes I mean if
you know you know this is an area that I
think I'm curious see and you know are
there biomarkers for something klepto
Fiji the discoverer of Fatah Fiji won a
Nobel Prize in 2006 616 and etapa G is
this notion of your body recycling
itself you know when a fasted state it
ends up kicking into a kapha G and a lot
of the benefits of fasting and Clark
restriction for longevity is often
attributed to the notion of
you're breaking down like kind of damage
cells and reusing those parts there's
not really a good biomarker for etaf
adji that I know of that I think can
send us nose up so there are just you
know you know more work to be done there
but yeah I mean I think going back to an
original stated question what is a
discussion of diabetes with keto with
with fasting so it's an interesting
discussion so it's basically the
philosophy of how what is the core root
cause of diabetes so one gets diagnosed
with diabetes if you have elevated blood
sugar right like your blood sugar is too
high so what happens in the body when
you have high blood sugar is that it
releases a hormone called insulin and
insulin is the hormone that basically
jams or sticks glucose into it cells so
you need insulin to absorb glucose so
why does this break in diabetics so the
traditional treatment of type 2 diabetes
is addition of more insulin it's the
notion that okay so for some reason the
insulin is not driven enough sugar to be
consumed or taken up by ourselves let's
inject more and if you're on that sort
of pathway you never sort of draw back
on the amount of insulin because you you
essentially associate your body to
insulin resistance you need more and
more insulin for the same glucose
response so there's an actually quite a
bit of work around this notion that
that's actually the wrong strategy to
treat diabetes what if you I mean you're
essentially giving an alcoholic more
alcohol if you understand the diabetes
of insulin resistance problem so what if
you feed or do it nutritionally through
a ketogenic diet which is a dialect
eighty percent fat very very heavily fat
meat moderate protein no carbohydrates
so you don't give the body glucose or I
do through fasting for
you just take away you know all all
macronutrients does this allow your body
to get used to having a lower insulin
state so your body can read up and get
more insulin sensitive so this is not
just a theory and it's not my theory
there's actually a number of interesting
resources to check out out there so dr.
Jason Fung a clinician based a
nephrologist based in Canada runs a
clinic in his treated thousands of
diabetics through a fasting approach and
there's another company based up in
Silicon Valley called verda health where
it's an app that coaches people through
a caring diet and they actually
published in a peer-reviewed journal
article showing that after a year people
onward on a Canadian diet are reversing
their diabetes meaning that they're
taking less insulin they are their h1
BAC which is a marker of kind of like
glucose it's like a running average of
how how much the sugars in your in your
in your blood is lower your fasted blood
glucose drops so this is not just like
me saying random theory this is like
being proved out and published so and I
think there's like you know a lot of
thought leaders and people out there
basically pushing this notion that we
need to update our nutritional
guidelines to take in the context that
diabetes is one of them literally
overall a third of us are pre-diabetic
and diabetic in America and we're
exercising more we're getting fatter
like people are getting on insulin never
get off of it's you know it's it's a
very pernicious problem and maybe it can
be solved through nutrition or fasting
is is is our hope
yep so I think it can - there's so many
studies now that are pointing towards
fasting and intermittent fasting being
really healthy we're talking about a lot
of the
is probably the easiest takeaway is
probably not gonna get a ketone drink
tomorrow but what you can do is you can
feel what happens to your body when it
drops into ketosis when you fast for 24
hours so just go one day eat at night
and then go one whole day without eating
wake up in the morning and see how you
feel at the end of that day get over
that hump there's one hump where your
stomach is and if you get past that when
you get past that see how you feel that
next day and pretty much that next day
you don't really think like oh I need to
eat I need to eat you're gonna feel like
that way at all and then that's what's
real that's what's really fascinating to
me like why do I feel like I don't need
to eat that day that second day Ron what
do you think about fasting do you
yeah I've been wanting to fast for 18
years now what's stopping you my
willpower on so many things is terrible
it's not just about what's stopping me
from not fasting you know what's
stopping me from quitting smoking
cigarettes or you know watching how much
I drink alcohol and whatnot so I'm just
old my willpower is shot to [ __ ] isn't
it fun to play the Ron play one time
with the fasting game you know it would
it would be great to meditate as well is
another thing on top of fasting there's
so many things that are my list of
things to do that uh you know I'm gonna
get to these things as soon as I'm done
sinning yeah as soon as I'm just done
walking with the devil you know we'll do
them together
Ron we'll do them together sweet I mean
I think it's like that's an interesting
point I think like we all know that
exercising is good for us I think all of
the it's well accepted that everyone you
know should exercise it's already
exercising and I think that fasting will
be concerned anew like exercise 2.0 it's
like we all know that it's
reasonable for you know us to be doing
some of us will do it more often than
others but it'll be just like a part of
like a healthy lifestyle so I always say
yeah I think I think Alan has a good
suggestion just start once I think it's
gonna kind of suck in the beginning but
it's it gets kind of Pleasant addictive
just like exercising gets coming yeah
Pleasant and addictive just like sex
well you're lying first you're all like
and then you figure it out and you're
like I'm well aware these are very
beneficial to me and I just you know you
get a start
yeah yeah we'll do it together think
together we'll help and that's a really
good takeaway and I hope that we can
share these sorts of guinea pig
experiences it's an it's strange going
through life without tampering with the
cultural norms that we abide every day
so that's that's why I get so attracted
to people that like to you know push and
pull and tinker and do things that are a
little different than the cultural norms
or even a lot different at times and one
of the main ones is this whole
indoctrination into eating three meals a
day every single day it just it was it
was not like that a long time ago it
some very recently turned into that with
this whole ubiquity in food you make so
much money to where you can go and do it
anytime you want eat anytime you want so
it's a very cool thing to pull the plug
on one of those societal norms and just
ya know and I've actually looked in the
history of this so I think you put
exactly the right point it is a recent
phenomenon that we have three meals a
day like why does that exist is this
some like heaven mandated truth like no
it is actually an industrial revolution
artifact like we were factory workers
and we need to do multiple shifts of
8-hour shifts a day and the most
efficient way to do that was like fuel
you up before shift get a
break in the middle and then at the end
you eat again and then at the end of the
second shift you eat at the end of
exhaust Theory yeah three so people look
at Roman culture one large mill a day a
lot of East Asian cultures and there are
two meals a day yeah and it's and it's
at the same I think realization that you
know we're not factory workers anymore
we're not farmers anymore like most of
us I mean if you're watching this
program you know you might be at work I
don't know but like a lot of us are
intellectual workers now yeah and I
argue that all of us will at some point
be intellectual creative workers like
you're just not gonna have a physical
job anymore like sorry like it's a
fridge dude the fact that there's a
refrigerator that you can go and open up
and access at any point you want that's
in your kitchen that changes the whole
thing like you're saying when you're
only eating that one meal with everybody
at dinnertime in the Roman history
you're finished that meal you're full
and you go and you're from whatever 6:00
p.m. until midnight there's no option
for you to go and access a fridge that
has food in it so you wait until the
next day what do you do when you wake up
you go and run your errands you do some
physical exercise and stuff and then you
know you're basically intermittently
fast throughout the day yeah you're a
really good way to intermittently
fastest just take us take a 6 or 8 hour
window of time from you can only eat at
noon and 8:00 p.m. or noon and 6:00 p.m.
or something yeah and when you wake up
in the morning don't eat eat at 12 and
then eat again at 6 or 8 and then don't
eat again at night and just that window
that puts you out an 18 hour or 16 hour
don't eat window and an 8 or 6 hour
eat window and that's intermittently
fast and which is also very interesting
to throw our bodies into that process
that happens so can can I use a ketone
drink to replace as a meal replacement
as well or no that's a good question so
we've gotten some we have some
interesting thoughts about that so it is
not a meal replacement in the sense that
you know
it doesn't have well if you look at that
if you look at the nutrition facts it is
zero grams fat zero grams protein zero
grams carbohydrate 120 calories so just
like Oh where's all the colors come from
well it's coming from ketones for about
eight ounces or 12 ounces it's a 2.2
ounce little okay's hunch running
calories and that's enough for do we
know approximately how much so
it'll at rest it will elevate your
ketone levels in your blood for four to
six hours and if you're doing intense
overbooking activity one to two hours on
it it'll in it for the people that might
know the quantitative measures it will
elevate your blood ketones to three to
five millimole which is equivalent to
like fasting for five to ten days what
does it taste like right now
it tastes like crazy check in help no I
it would be I would love for it tastes
like chicken it tastes pretty crazy take
some fried chicken TV it's bitter it's
[Music]
kind of like rubbing like nail polish
remover bitter and and so it's kind of
like you just yeah we wouldn't you're
done you just shot you just shot it
shoot it cuz it's not politically or
ball - yeah it's not pleasurable that's
turbot I mean we didn't talk a bit y-yes
exists but yeah it's it's like kind of
chemically I just something it's the
true yeah yeah yeah
and so the the question about that was
oh like fasting like can we use it for
fasting so I think one of the
interesting things about this is that we
think could be very good adjunct for
fasting because it's not insulin genic
isn't like trigger a lot of insulin and
well it also is an appetite suppressant
through the ghrelin effect so imagine if
you can you know basically as you sort
of fast the user thick sort of kick you
into a state so one of the reasons why I
tax these forever though well it's safe
I mean I think you know a
that's something that I we have to do
some longitudinal studies well we'll get
back to you yeah and I think it's like
that's what it gets interesting I was
gonna say that one of the reason why
fasting is hard is because it takes a
bit of time for your body to kick in the
ketosis yeah correct right I saw that
yeah so basically like you not eating
sugar so your blood sugar drops but your
body takes time especially if you're not
using not used to being ketotic at all -
like generate ketones so her body sucks
that using generating ketones you could
write whenever you know blood sugar so
you're just like you just have like no
energy like you're nothing going in your
brain because you have no sugar and your
buddy sucks at making ketones because
it's not useful yeah
so why that pure you so you get stock
keto fluid a patient like it sucks yeah
you're a angry angry so like all these
terms are describing this notion that
like you don't get enough fuel to your
brain you're like your buddy I gotta eat
yeah yeah but what if you kid again BAM
like he just insulin get into a deep
state of overcoming down are you coming
with blood sugars that's pretty cool so
don't go to the angry state yeah that's
the interesting so I think that's
interesting
I think longitudinally I mean I think
yeah I you know we're gonna do more so
one it's safe it's considered a food
ingredient but of course you know let's
do more and more studies to double
triple check that it's you know yeah
that you know one could do it every day
for you know forever ever what are our
idea of open investors I mean who are
the investors if you can disclose yeah
so one of our lead investors Andreessen
Horowitz Silicon Valley venture capital
firm Congrats they're great yeah some of
our we were also backed by interesting
individual investors including Marissa
Mayer former CEO of Yahoo Tony Shea
founder CEO of Zappos actually one of
the more fun investors is Joe Montana
legend haha it's so cool he's been
helpful opening some of the doors again
into the NFL yeah of course
and then who got who who did the door
for
Oxford and NIH uh well that was you know
that was I don't know me
kind of you yeah good good yeah damn
this this is well backed yeah this is
well back and so what do you guys have
for time well your because you're
already at a point where the company's
profitable yeah where you're paying your
overhead and your so I think it's one of
the gap revenue things did you still
have to pay for your overhead of your
employees yeah absolutely well yeah
we're investing into the company yeah
we're rescue happen II yeah yeah this
we're throwing out revenues sure yeah
it's awesome and so right now it's 30
bucks for the you said 2.2 outs of
ketones 25 grams over Astra and right
now it's 30 bucks for that and that's
going to mostly professional sports
teams and I mean it's just expensive I'm
like I know like it's expensive like I'm
not gonna say no it's it's it's not you
know we should drinks every day it's
just expensive what we'll do is we'll
have to find new I would have asked you
to bring one yeah we could have just
shot it and like measured and done and
then yeah yeah right here on yeah well
we'll do that we'll bring you back we'll
do that whole session that'll be fun to
show that as well
let's run me through a couple do you
have something else you want to bring
about bring to thought about about human
before we run you through a couple
simulations
yeah well just the last thread to talk
about you know how hard is to start
fasting that's one of the reasons why we
start we fast we realize that the
community the culture part up eating
like you're just we're just trained to
eat we're trying to go to happy hours
okay I don't know like our people do
you'll want to like eat at like 5:00
p.m. and drink like some yeah it's fine
for sometimes but like I just like baked
into like American culture it's like
what if you've got Colo working yeah I
was like what do you have culture around
like helping people fast and I think
that was like a cordon yeah of we fast
and whites growing so quickly is that go
it is easier to you know do fasting with
other people like if you're just passing
by yourself say oh and this person the
weirdo like why are you not eating lunch
and it sucks you're like just answer
questions so you're just gonna like live
your life you're so weird man you're not
even blind and then you're sitting there
everyone's eating some delicious food
and you're just yes I think that's where
I think community is like we fast yeah
are helpful can you create it can we
create a new culture around being
quantitative towards human performance
and where can we find we fast
you can find our Facebook group I just
type in we fast yeah or go to lwy we we
fast so w/e FASD cool just google it
you'll find it usually like the slack
group or the Facebook group beautiful
that is so important like you said like
we've been talking about the first
action item join a community get
involved fasting talk to your friends
that do it do for the day and then
experience guinea pig on yourself
experience how it feels all right all
right Jeff let's see what we got for you
here
all right let's start you off with how
do we maximize human potential hmm
how do we maximize human potential is
that individual or like all of humanity
we're gonna be a little bit of both if
you want one at a time yeah yes I think
on an individual basis I think there's a
lot of culture of conforming or
averaging to the mean so I don't I think
it's like a I I think like the topics
that you bring on this program are
inspiring people to break out of like
this confirmation this this this
reversion to the mean phenomenon in
people like it's kind of scary to be
like I want to be the crazy person talk
about enhancing human performance oh the
crazy person talking about you know
politics or transhumanism you know so I
think there needs to be a cultural
acceptance around letting people do
crazy [ __ ] and like almost encouraging
that behavior because and I think but
maybe you know I think in any population
right like there's gonna be a lot of
people that are in the mean cohort but
like any sort of progress
our other crazy people doing stuff on
the side and like half of them maybe all
of 90% of them are doing these actually
stupid stuff but like the 10% or the 1%
of people that are doing crazy stuff but
it's actually genius stuff that's
progress that's potential so I guess it
kind of relates to the population sample
of all humans right you need those 1%
people to go do crazy stuff to like
create the maximize potential everyone
so we need more like Elon Musk's and
Jeff Bezos is and even just the average
person even just drew yeah but even
average can be yes can we increase the
morning right yeah here's something very
interesting you can be the 1% on the
BART there's a hundred people in a train
car and all of them are you know
standing there sitting there just
stationary sedentary doing whatever
they're doing on their phones whatever
they're doing
why don't you don't don't feel
uncomfortable to you know do a little
dance you know move your body around do
some stretching you know get get to get
the blood flowing do a little dancing
thing you know I do that on the BART all
the time one time I was this was so
fascinating I was actually rolling my
eyes you know like this because it's
really good to roll your eyes around
like this everyone swap ok so I'm doing
that on Bart right and then I finally
look I blink a bunch and I look forward
and there's this group of girls that are
all pointing at me going they thought if
they thought I was possessed it was so
funny so it's stuff like that I don't
know if you're familiar with with logan
paul oh yeah again just very very
eccentric very weird very different like
you know doing whatever is all the times
and stuff and that again it's there's
nobody else that's going like that crazy
all the time and stuff and i think
you're right that empowering people to
not revert back to the medium but to
empower craziness you know has been bold
for both business endeavors and
moonshots and things like that but also
for things like Bruno and Copernicus and
Galileo for yeah science exactly but I
think it also just makes your life
interesting I'd I like you so much we
want to be like the ninth
that like hates their job right like I
think it's really sad that people hate
their job like I'm so sad but like that
I mean but I think it's like you you
spend like the best hours your day like
doing something you hate like you're
mortgaging your time for some money so
you can live on the weekend and just
like get out soon I understand like it
sucks that you got a pay bill you gotta
take care of a you know there's livings
there's always work to do that will pay
your bills that you love more oh I would
like to think so I think where's always
I think there's like even if you're in
the service industry pick what you want
to do in the service industry if you
want to serve tables serve tables quit
the job at Starbucks or wherever else
you're dreading if you want to to sell
something on Commission go and work your
way into selling something on Commission
slowly over time there's always a way to
figure out how to do something that you
like doing more than what you're
currently doing in that specific
industry it's almost I can't even think
of one scenario right now and there
might be one that where you're just
absolutely positively stuck and [ __ ]
and what really nobody would hire you
for 1 billion different positions on the
planet I think so so so it's good that's
a really good point about maximizing
potential I like that being different
striving for that
how about what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world I
think someone just fully self
actualizing is I think super is very
beautiful I think it's very rare I think
again going back to the previous topic I
think we feel constrained to fit some
sort of societal average silo arm I
think when you see so much like bully
just being themselves it just like
inspire I mean this could be an artists
commune business could be an
entertainment right like I think he you
you kind of know it when you see it like
when you see it you're like a singer
they just fully you know like I'm just
bawling out this is me
yeah like damn like that's attractive
right I think it's like sort of
attractive energy to people that are
just self actualizing in
full unbridled unapologetic way I think
all of us should aspire to that is would
be my hope
gosh that's that's definitely and
probably my top answer of of what's the
most beautiful thing in the world I do
totally resonate with that obviously
just coming from Robyn's
self-actualization we really need to
figure out how people become what they
are made here to do to find that meaning
and purpose in life and bring it to the
world what do you think is the purpose
or the meaning of life I mean I think
there's a biological answer and there's
like a philosophical answer
what are they you know you know in terms
in strict terms of biology we're just
here to procreate our DNA and expand
more you know more more entities just
having our DNA more rocks orbiting stars
well I mean the rocks don't have our
inanimate by me it's like you know and
in some terms yeah maybe like Genghis
Khan succeeded in a biological way of
like ranking are you doing well you know
as a purpose right like he has you can
ascribe like he still has the top points
already I mean I think that is death I
mean it might not be politically correct
but that's the only one you have a way
to rank rank it life success right there
you have the most progeny out of all of
humankind no no like I have no I'm not
implying any ethical moral view on that
but sight I mean I think philosophically
yeah I don't think there's any universal
objective or value system I think you
know I am that was shall not kill but I
mean I think a society does kill people
right right like it like we there's
death pets sentences and there
is more like it is okay to kill some
people if they're bad right if they can
kill that's right so so there already
are caveats right so it's like Dallas
will not kill at a service over yeah and
I don't want to kill people actually
don't but I need T's into it to go maybe
sometimes you want to you know eliminate
some people threats we'll put it that
way round you have something quick I
know
no I gotta have no comment on the kill
thing yeah well thou shalt not kill Ron
I know you I know you're thinking of
something back there come on throw it
out there what week we kill week it's
part of who we are we can't yeah I mean
I think it's just reality it's just the
fact it's never gonna go away
well what if okay it's part of who we
are okay
evolution okay cool evolution evolves
human psychology in essence and presence
evolved away from that yeah I may think
that's a ma it's and it's interesting
philosophical discussion can we you know
is there a state where there's no common
I mean so I think killing people is like
the extreme version of extreme
competition right like there's always
some competition you have like
intellectual battles around like
businesses trying to capture market
share you have sport battles
I want to dunk on you you want to dunk
on me I want to score touchdown on you
but I would say that like killing
someone is a basically like the the
perverse case extreme case of all of
competition so I guess in one sense like
you eliminate competition then you can
eliminate the desire to kill people
I think yeah I think we're on is gonna
point like you know people are just kind
of come at it
it's like I think one of the reasons why
we make progress there's some sort of
competitive definitely instinct in human
so it's just like okay is there
enlightened future probably like we
eliminate you know conflicts I'd like to
think so but I don't know the solution
Allen is there no killer inside of you
I mean well if you really think about it
you're 25 years old it has there never
been a thought doesn't it go through all
of our minds I'm gonna kill this bastard
I want to kill him I don't I want to
kill by never it's probably once every
week or every two weeks okay yeah that's
my case yeah yeah but but at the same it
but we don't do it we don't do it some
do it's fun because we run the
simulation in our head that's what's the
exciting part run the simulation and
then you don't do it because you know
you don't want to go to jail for the
rest of your life I ran the simulation
at Kyle's Judy the other night there was
two punks going at it with each other
and I got like I'm gonna get out of here
before I get shot what a stray bullet so
I was out but yeah we're evolved enough
that we don't we you know we see the
simulation in our head and we say okay
we're good yeah but as some people don't
some people manifest it and that's just
the way it is this has been a really
solid discussion we we should definitely
you know this is why I would love to you
know be able to go on that more we
totally can
so the fact that we still eat and our
animals is as long as we still kill to
eat you know all bets are off you know
in order for us to be non killers we
have to stop killing to eat okay but
when you pluck an apple off of a tree
and you remove it from its source of
energy are you killing the apple
we're gonna Soylent Green is that where
we're going with our diet I just I just
wonder where do we really need to get to
a point where we're making everything
from scratch from human engineering
rather than from nature because we don't
want to kill even a sleeve of spinach er
yeah I think that's a good question
right I mean I think that's i think that
was Ron's point like we kill animals for
consumption billions of animals animals
a year I think it's an interesting
ethical question and I think it was
actually raised in you know homo Deus
you know the Indians novels that so
we're essentially enslaving animal
species yeah in eating them correct like
we are farming them and these are like
somewhat pseudo sentient beings that can
like recognize they're young and they're
humans they have a maze they do they do
and I did someone who thinks oh like
people don't think about it but let me
ask you this if you could be if you
could home if you had to cut out like
one animal what would it be what would
you what would you lose in your diet you
want to start with that I don't I just I
can't get over the look that I had in
with the gorillas I've told this story
before
you're not eating gorillas I know but
there's just there was just this
piercing look in this photo that my
friend took at Disney World when he was
travelling through their zoo area and he
took this photo and I he showed me the
photo and I don't think he noticed but I
zoomed all the way in on his photo to
the gorilla in the corner of the photo
and the gorilla was looking right at the
[ __ ] bus that was moving and hit
basically right at almost right at the
lens right of the passengers that were
all foot photographing area and the
gorilla was just looking like like this
and you could look in the gorillas eyes
and you could just see that the gorilla
knew what the [ __ ] was going on that
finally had to become conscious enough
to realize that you're just a tiny bit
more intelligent than me and you figured
out how to build this world and then you
me here and then then the argument is of
course oh well then this they live
longer they live healthier in the zoo's
they live blah blah yeah conversation
for hesitate brother so you and I can
talk about one-on-one and who we are you
know as we got to who we look at these
yeah
primates in them and who we are when we
look at spinach I just a pan psychism is
interesting and if it's gonna be brought
up it's something that I don't think we
really I will show us broccoli I mean
who says that you don't think your
broccoli I prefer for you to affiliate
me and I call me broccoli now on okay so
good that was very solid now let's do
let's do this question cuz this kind of
led to where we were where we're going
what do you think about eight people
having as much wealth as the bottom four
billion people and what do you think
about AI and genetic engineering and
neural prosthetics and robotics and all
these technologies nanotech that are
just exacerbating wealth inequality the
gap even though Pinker's right all
everybody's coming up over time what do
you think about that gap and would do
what do you what should we do about it
yeah I'm I think there's a historical
argument that when you have that kind of
income inequality or just wealth
inequality you get revolution yeah weird
the great leveler right you know Walter
show great book I mean I think you you
have one of the end points of capitalism
assuming that you know the best people
that acquiring capital get better at
better at clarin capital as they kind of
vacuum up more and more power and
influence than I think you see the end
end stage of capitalism
right keep going this is what does that
lead to you see little vacuum right of
like get better and better capitalism
more and more vacuuming what does what
happens then
well I mean I think you just take the
projection in the future if you continue
in this path right you just have one
uber guide and everyone has all the
Walternate in the world and everyone
else is like a like a like a peon so
obviously I think not many of us want to
live in that in that civilization I mean
I think is being towards like so I I
mean I think it's I don't know I'd only
there's like a define answer to what is
the atopic Society essentially or what
is like an ideal Society I think you
know as an industry work on human
performance I think what we can do is
make sure that we bring the technology
in a market in a way that's responsible
all right like it's not I I think
there's some technocrats who just say
that technology's a democratizing force
like look at the smartphone used to be
for you know Angela iPhone that rich
group can use now there's like Android
phones or $10 and people in Africa are
like doing mobile banking so it's gonna
be like a obvious path for good I don't
think it's inevitable
I think that it takes industry
government regulators people to work
together to democratize access so I
think that's something that we should be
cognizant about Bill technologies and
make it available for everyone and I
guess that answers the question directly
like do I think that like the Karnes
ASCO is optimal no I I think what
patchwork would you do what Patrick
would I do
I don't know I I think it's it's I mean
I think the obvious some you know the
obvious solutions don't seem to work
that well right like the wealth
redistribution or taxing who gets
allocate that resources is that even
well done right I think that's a good
argument that more conservatives would
say you know you have what you give you
tax the rich people give it to the
government government allocates
resources I don't know if people
generally agree that the government is
the best allocate our resources even
from both side of the spectrum I think
both you know most people say you know
government's not the greatest at that
like people are upset the government
services all the time I think there
might be some aspect to that I hate to
rely on charity of rich people - right
like I don't think it's like oh you know
let the rich people get a lot of power
and then like they'll sign the Warren
Buffett giving pledge I don't know if I
trust I think you got to be a killer to
like be a billionaire you have you are a
shark right like you've acquired a lot
of power and money in a really short
period of time you know on you know you
you were aggressive to like quite how
much power that quickly so I think it's
I don't if I trust people to go you flip
a switch that you won and now you're
gonna be like really generous now I
don't know if that's you know I don't
know if I we should just trust that rich
people are gonna be like you know
benevolent but me there's a culture
thing maybe it's like hey like we like
what some rich people are doing with
their capital like you you could get
this sense that you know some
billionaires are putting their wealth to
interesting projects like Rockets like
longevity so maybe like a cultural thing
or you know I guess I like I hate to say
a the government meets a mandate like a
tax or like forces people to do stuff I
I'm reluctant to say something like that
so I think that's like a very slippery
slope down to the thort Arianism I don't
know the maca of the masses or but I
think there's you know can we encourage
incentive eyes you know the topic
richest people in the world to allocate
resources their resources in a smart way
I think there's something to be done
there yeah I love it I don't have like
it easy one two three yeah you ventured
down so many different conversations
about it so you you've done a good
amount of thought about it which is good
are we alone in the cosmos I guess this
is another philosophical question I
would say I don't think so I don't have
any data to say yes or no but I I think
life is I guess alone right I mean it's
like there's other other life forms yeah
I don't think there's any
anthropocentric uniqueness of humans so
I imagine that you know in this vast
cosmos there are other living things out
there but I'll have data either way do
you think we're in a computer simulation
I remember I saw your Jordan Peterson
interview and I think he answered in a
kind of a funny way where I was like oh
what's the definition of reality and
versus simulation now that was like an
interesting kind of question I think I
guess like the pragmatic answer is what
would you do or pragmatic approaches
like what would you do differently if
you were in a simulation or if you were
in reality and to me I would do the same
I would completely sink I don't think my
life would change if I knew I was in a
computer simulation like would your life
change would you do anything different
the number one thing about that question
is the expansion of one's awareness to
the dimensions of understanding the
question that's a big thing the the
general answer of would I change my
behavior or not if I knew or not I'm not
quite sure I'm not quite sure because if
I knew for
sure that I was in a simulation I would
probably go berserk in this [ __ ]
but you would have the same you would
feel the same pain if like you you like
there's some simulation that is like
actually inflicting pain or inflicting
joy yeah but we're finding meaning and
purpose in this life by climbing up this
competence hierarchy and trying to
impact people and build the world
because if we go berserk in this [ __ ]
and everyone else agrees to do the same
then we're good
one sec one sec I'm Nadia we'll be right
back all right that if you really think
about it we're all agreeing to the
social norm and the social fabric
because we think we're in base reality
and that we need to get to the next
planets and the next stars and figure
out the whole suffering and the control
of the rock thing otherwise we're gonna
potentially go through an existential
crisis and even extinguish the light of
consciousness in general so again I do
think it does change it does it does it
change for you after don't think it
changes anything for me like we if you
knew there was a creator that yeah I
guess it's like physics in the math so
you would say you would just say you
would try to like contact the simulation
trader oh absolutely
like me and you'd be so fascinating to
observe all of the rocks orbiting star
systems different masses of the rock
different masses of the star different
different positions in the Goldilocks
zone orbiting that star different
gravity on the planet different
consciousness what do you think of the
Bostrom's theory that like yeah or
basically I mean his notion is that yeah
or basically likely to be in a
simulation if you assume that you can
build up computers in a way that can
simulate consciousness and you assume
that you know civilizations can not kill
each other before you can make those
computers then it's more likely than not
that
in a simulation because the simulation
can make a simulation there's like a
huge stack of simulations so if you
would change your behavior why why don't
you just assume that in a simulation and
just like act like you know you're gonna
talk to God
I bet it's kind of what I do really that
is kind of what I do and that's kind of
what this essence of the show is really
about that's why it's called simulation
and once one expands their minds to the
dimension of what simulation theory is
all about then again just the whole idea
of yeah okay cosmos are so vast time
lines been so long potential to harvest
a star or harvest nuclear fusion and
compute the worlds that we live in great
great that's fascinating and then
furthermore is when we really get down
into it then we get to understand like
we were talking about all the different
variables that can be tweaked for all
these different planets around star
systems and that's really where all of
the fascination in the conversation lies
this what would it be like to be that
deity whatever that being is whatever
that program or whatever that one human
or ten humans or one computer is that is
figuring that out
again I'm anthropomorphizing what the
thing is but that is just in itself just
extremely fascinating and I think again
it just expands the mind to new
dimensions it's great to even be able to
talk about this in a way that is very
thought-provoking it's thanks to other
people like you that enjoy the question
and the conversation so alright that was
that was epic we chatted so much about
enhancing human potential human
performance
we talked extensively about ketones why
they're important why you're building
them into our world now I've chosen that
why athletes and people in the military
are all over it now and why soon we'll
be on our convenience store shelves for
very affordable prices and we give you
guys at home an action item just do it
suck it up be conscientious sign a
social contract with yourself I'm not
going to eat for 24 hours wake up the
next morning observe how you feel
give that a go feel dropping into
ketosis what it actually feels like and
then one day we'll get to that
convenience store and we'll be able to
just knock it right in it'll be great
check out human is it just H V M n
dot-com yes awesome we'll put the link
in the bio and then we'll also put their
Twitter will put the possessed Twitter
as well and what a blast week we also
covered so many simulation topics guys
if you had a good time yeah did you have
a good time yeah as a fun conversation
yeah it's great hell yeah hell yeah hell
yeah I'm happy at a good time guys again
like comment subscribe we'd love to hear
from you share with other people if you
found this to be useful
join us on patreon for exclusive content
become a supporter of us so we can keep
this beautiful studio space thank you
Ron Vargas or a director and producer
thanks to all of our high-level patrons
Robert Griffiths
the clear one family office to my card
and family office thank you guys and
thanks for tuning in and see you next
time
[Music]